- Hello, hi everyone.
Thank you, alright.
Maximizing productivity
with the Amazon Q Developer.
And if you've been around all week,
then you'll know,
it's not called Q Developer
CLI Agent anymore,
it's actually called the Kiro CLI,
which is a lot easier for me to say.
So I work for Pluralsight.
We're a company that helps people upskill
their workforce so that they can deliver
their digital transformation needs.
One of the things that we did recently
is this, tech forecast,
it's like a, whacking 50 page document,
but we interviewed 1500 tech executives,
IT people, and business leaders
to try and find out
what kind of challenges and skills,
gaps and issues they were facing.
And you can download it as well.
But what we found
was that the next phase of AI
of is of course gonna be all focused
on governance, and ethics as
well as return on investment.
Cloud, of course, being the key enabler
with services from AWS like Federal
and SageMaker enabling AI for all of us.
And for the last three years,
running the top technical gaps
have always been cybersecurity,
basic foundational core cloud skills,
cloud architecture skills,
cloud security skills,
and, of course, AI and machine learning.
So when I read this report,
one of the things
that I thought straight away
was that it's never been more important
for all of us to keep on top
of all of these new trends,
the new skills that we all
gonna need going forward,
which is exactly why we're here, right?
So show of hands,
who's already done one of the following,
and it could be that you've
done multiple of these things.
Used Amazon Q Developer before?
Used the Q Developer CLI agent,
now called the Kiro CLI agent?
Have you used and had success
with any of the Claude models?
Or used any other coding assistant?
Alright, well you're in the right place,
because we're gonna find out
how I maximize my own
productivity with it?
So we'll talk a little bit
about how to get started
with Q Developer/Kiro.
I've got some basic simple sample prompts
that you can start off
with and adapt to make your own,
oh sorry, trigger happy,
got some demos, mistakes to avoid as well,
and how we can all thrive
on in this age of AI,
and keep our skills up-to-date,
and really succeed with it,
and enable it to give us superpowers.
Finally, I've got some resources
if you wanna learn more.
Alright, so when it
comes to getting started
with Q Developer/Kiro,
there's three different ways.
So you can use it in the AWS console,
you can get troubleshooting
advice from Q developer.
It's getting better and better.
You can also use the Kiro IDE,
which is a fork of VS code,
if you're used to using
an IDE on the daily
it's a copy of a VS code
that's been augmented with the Kiro.
It's been Kiro vibe.
So it's using Claude for
the kind of the assistant
and the chat capabilities.
It's got the ability to hook it up
to AWS MCP servers as well.
But we are here to talk
about the Kiro CLI,
which is basically a chat agent
that you can use in your terminal.
And if you don't feel like
firing up a full on IDE,
or maybe you don't work
in an IDE very much
or you just like working
in the terminal, I do.
There's no bells and whistles.
It's simple and basic.
It does what it said on the tin.
So if you like working in the terminal,
then go with the Kiro CLI.
Alright, so in terms of
sample prompts to try,
I've got a few to share with you.
First of all, it goes beyond Q & A,
because it can actually do stuff for you.
You can allow it to take
action in your AWS account,
and do things like creating
a new EC2 instance,
that's a clone of an existing instance,
and specifying particular
security groups or VPCs et cetera.
Help with troubleshooting.
Yeah, if you've got an error,
it could be an error with AWS,
or an error with Python,
or any other popular programming language,
Kiro can help you in your terminal.
It can read and write files
on your local machine,
so it can review your
CloudFormation templates,
or your IAM policies that
are within the folder
that you're working,
and suggest improvements for security,
best practice, et cetera.
Now, a little bit about my role.
So I work for a training company,
a company that enables organizations
to upskill their staff basically,
and my job is a mix
of kind of non-technical,
and technical work,
and I describe myself really
as like a cloud architect,
a builder, content creator.
And there's this kind of unusual mix
of tech and non-tech work.
So I work a lot with documents,
doing lots of research, developing slides,
developing tutorials, that kind of thing.
And I also do loads of hands
on technical implementation working
with AWS every single day.
So troubleshooting things that don't work,
trying to understand the way
that new products work,
that kind of thing,
but yet loads and loads
of troubleshooting.
But the good news is that
I can use the Kiro CLI
in every single area of my role.
Okay, onto my demos,
and I've got a few
little demos to show you.
First of all, I use it a lot
when I can't remember an AWS CLI command,
and I can't remember them all,
especially when I'm trying to stop
an Amazon Comprehend
sentiment analysis job.
That's not a command I use every day.
So I can get Kiro to help me with that.
Let's see it in action.
Alright, so I'm starting a
Kiro CLI chat session just
in my terminal, on my Mac.
Next, I'm gonna select
which model I want to use.
Ask my question.
Here, it's using the AWS
documentation MCP server.
So it's not gonna hallucinate,
it's gonna give me an up-to-date answer
from the latest documentation,
and there you go.
It's given me the information I need
so I don't need to mess around trying
to use this CLI command
and making mistakes.
Next, I'm getting it
to help me troubleshoot
an error I'm getting with AccessDenied,
and asking it how should I
approach troubleshooting?
Let's see what it does.
Oh sorry, I went too quick.
And it's coming back
with like a step-by-step
approach telling me
what I need to check.
My IAM policy permissions,
S3 bucket policy, et cetera.
Verify Bucket Ownership.
It's even giving me some AWS CLI commands
that I can use to perform some
of this troubleshooting.
Verify Object Lock, as well.
So it's very, very thorough coming up
with lots of different suggestions.
It does actually go faster than this.
I slowed it down from my demo
so I could see what's going on.
So then it's asking,
do I want further help
with investigating any of those areas?
Alright, review my IAM policy
for security best practices.
Let's see what it comes up with.
So once again, it's gonna read my file
on my local machine,
and give me the best practices,
pinpoint all my security loopholes
that I've left in that policy.
And there we go,
overly permissive resource specification,
unfortunately and it's coming up
with some recommended
improvements giving me
the code I need to actually
improve that policy,
and it can actually
rewrite the policy for me,
or write a new file, or do nothing.
Just give me the suggestions.
There we are.
It's asking me,
do I want it to actually
upgrade the policy?
Next, how to use boto3
to invoke a foundation
model in Amazon Bedrock.
Well, when Bedrock first came out,
it was quite difficult
to get your head around
how to actually call it,
how to use the SDK, et cetera.
I did actually try to get this
to get the Amazon Q developer CLI
to help me with this back in the day,
and I didn't have an awful lot of success,
but now with Kiro, I mean it's brilliant.
It gives me absolutely loads
of information that's accurate.
It's all coming from the
AWS documentation as well,
and less opportunity for it to hallucinate
because we're using the MCP servers,
and there we go.
It's given me the Python
code that I need to run.
Lots of great examples.
It's pointing out
that you're gonna need
different parameters
for different models as well.
There we are.
Okay, in my role,
I do a lot of testing or
testing different use cases
or demonstrating different use cases.
And sometimes I need to
create some synthetic data
and I can use Kiro, the Kiro CLI
to help me with that as well.
And it really quickly
creates a 100 examples
of synthetic data that I
can easily use to test with.
And it's asking me,
do I trust it to actually write
that file to my local file system?
Another Bedrock question.
What are the best practices
when setting a common
request body parameters?
Difficult phrase to say.
And once again,
this is gonna use the AWS
documentation MCP server.
This one is also actually useful
if you are preparing for
the AI practitioner exam
because this, these kind
of parameters come up.
Things like top-k and
top-p, that kind of thing.
Once again, it's using the MCP server.
It's asking me to trust it.
Do I trust it for that session
to actually use that MCP server?
And it will actually read
the documentation a number
of times because I'm just asking it,
I guess quite an in-depth question
to tell me what are the
common request body parameters
rather than giving anything specific.
So it will read the
documentation a few times
and come back with what
are the common parameters,
some best practices, some example
configurations, et cetera.
Create a diagram for me.
Sometimes in my role,
I've gotta create diagrams
to explain my rationale,
and my thinking to other
people in the team,
or to make sure that I'm
doing something properly
to validate my own thinking,
to give me a checklist,
checking through all the things
that I need to create.
And getting the Q,
sorry, I wanna say Q CLI.
The Kiro CLI to help me
with that is gonna save me a few minutes.
There's a diagrams MCP
server that you can hook in
and it's going to create
a little diagram for me.
So it's a three tier application
with application load balancer,
elastic container service,
and a data layer in Aurora.
You can see it's hooked in
the AWS diagram MCP server.
And it's gonna create
this diagram, and ask me,
do I want to save it to my local machine?
There we go.
So it saved it to my local machine.
And here's a diagram, it's pretty good.
So this would be great for me to be able
to have a conversation
with a colleague explaining
my rationale and my thinking
around a certain architecture
that I'm developing.
Okay, mistakes to avoid.
Hopefully none of these are
gonna be a surprise for you.
So, hallucinations.
AI can of course,
and will of course still make mistakes.
We don't believe everything
that we read on the internet
or hear on the internet.
So we shouldn't believe everything
that gets delivered by AI,
and make sure that we
fact check everything,
especially when we're working in,
you know, production systems.
How to avoid it?
You can make sure that
when you're customizing,
you're using up-to-date high
quality and relevant data.
And we can also use
the MCP servers as well
to make sure that we are grounding
those answers in something
that we know is correct.
And of course, validate.
So request it to give you citations
of where it got information from.
Another mistake that I hear about
that's quite common is just Over-reliance
and not approaching AI
with a kind of a healthy
dose of skepticism,
and really just an
Over-reliance without verifying.
So really we should all be treating AI,
of course, as an assistant,
not an authority.
It works for us, not,
we don't work for it.
And it should support our decision making,
not be the source of the decision itself
with a human deciding
whether this is the
right thing to do or not.
Of course, when it comes to data sharing,
when we're using the free
tier on any kind of service,
we should be careful
because often the free tier can be using
our data to retrain the model.
That was certainly true in
the case of a Q developer.
It was by default using the data
that you put in there,
but you can opt out.
So be sure to check your settings in all
of the tools that you're using
whenever using the free tier of anything,
and take care before you're providing
any confidential type data anyway.
So how do we all thrive
in this new age of AI?
Well, what I hear from our customers,
and from talking to people
here at re:Invent as well,
is that there really is a
rising demand for people
who can start using these tools
to give them superpowers.
Understanding their strengths,
and their limitations.
What are they great at,
what are they not so great at?
And it's changing all the time.
Being able to adapt quickly as well,
and being able to take on board
new things as they happen.
Tap adapt to changing technologies,
and technologies changing in the way
that we can and can't use them.
So really just having that ability
to kind of roll with it,
work effectively with these new tools
as well as bring context,
ethics and empathy, and humanity
to the technology that we're using.
Ultimately blending AI
with human expertise.
So my challenge for all of you
is to start experimenting
with the Kiro CLI yourself
in your own daily activities,
and start small
with some kind of
routine low stakes tasks,
the kind of things that
I've shown you today.
Validate the output that you
get with your own output.
And be sure to track
your productivity gain
so that you can understand where time
is being saved or time is not being saved
because you end up correcting something,
and fixing something that was so you know,
far away from where you wanted to be.
Share successes with your teams,
and I think also share the things
that didn't go so well.
Sharing the failures.
And keep experimenting 'cause
it's changing all the time.
And you might have used a Q Developer CLI
or Q Developer itself in the past,
and not been very impressed,
but it's certainly changing.
It's changing all the time
with updates happening every single week.
Kiro runs on Claude.
So if you like using Claude,
I would definitely
recommend giving it a go.
And if you'd like to know more,
I have a couple of articles,
one on the use of AWS MCP servers
with the Q CLI/Kiro,
and 10 ways that I use this technology
to save my time in my role,
and that's kind of a expanded
version of this talk.
If you would like to learn more,
you can visit us at Pluralsight
to find out about all the
different content that we have.
We have content ranging from
pretty much any certification
that you can imagine
when it comes to cloud.
Any AWS certification,
loads of Q developer content,
loads of AI content.
Come and have a chat with us.
We're at Booth 139,
which is right over the
other side of the hall.
And yeah, you can also pick up
a copy of this like document.
Yeah, which you have.
Thank you.
And that's it, that's all for me.
Thank you so much for coming everyone.
At the end of the day,
I will be hanging around here,
if anybody, like anyone
would like to have a chat.